قالت الاداره العسكريه في الدفاعات الجويه
تتعامل مع هجوم جوي يستهدف المدينه عمليات
جنوب اوكرانيا ان القوات الروسيه تهاجم
الجنوبيه اوكرانيا بمسيرات مفخخه وان هناك
تهديدا بوجود هجوم صاروخي وقال رئيس
الاداره العسكريه في
انفجارات تدوي في مدينه كريفي جنوب الشرق
اوكرانيا من زاكوريا ينضم الينا مراسلنا
حسان مسعود حسان انطلاقا مما ذكرناه ماذا
عن اخر التطورات الميدانيه
نعم وسيله التطورات الميدانيه هي تشير الى
تواصل المعارك على عدد من الجبهات على طول
خط الجبهه الممتد من الشرق من دنياتك
وتحديدا من شمال وجنوب باخموت حيث تقول
القوات الاوكرانيه انها تنفذ هجمات
لمحاوله تطويق المدينه وتحرز تقدما جزئيا
عند تلك الجبهه في المنطقه الشماليه
تحديدا وكذلك
ترتبط بالتطورات عند جبهه تافريا الواقعه
جنوبي مقاطعه وكذلك جنوبي هذه المقاطعه
مقاطعه هنا تقول القوات الاوكرانيه انها
تحرز ايضا محاولات للتقدم عند هذه الجبهه
وان ببضع كيلومترات فقط عند اكثر من نقطه
تحديدا عند المنطقه الواقعه بين مقاطعتي
هناك محاولات للتقدم بعد اعلان القوات
الاوكرانيه على سيطرتها على اربع في تلك
النقطه القوات الروسيه تحاول ان تعود الى
هذه البلدات لسيما بلدات ماكاريفكا الا ان
القوات الاوكرانيه تقول انها تتصدى لهذه
الهجمات وتحرج تقدما
لمئات الامطار في هذه الجبهه اما ايضا في
جبهه زابولوجيا تحديدا في المنطقه الغربيه
من هذه الجبهه هناك محاولات التقدم للقوات
الاوكرانيه عند بلده تسمى وهي تتجه باتجاه
فينيسيا
هذه البلده او المدينه المهمه ايضا
بالنسبه للقوات الروسيه التي تسيطر عليها
جنوبي مقاطعه هذه المحاولات للتقدم في
اطار ما تسميه الهجوم المضاد تاتي
بالتزامن مع خسف متواصل من الجانب الروسي
تحديدا خلال الليل للمدن الواقعه في عمق
هذه الجبهات في عمق جبهه زابولوجيا باتجاه
الشمال الغربي مدينه هي مسقط راس الرئيس
الاوكراني وهي مدينه مهمه في هذه الجبهه
وهي مدينه تعرضت مره اخرى لقصف صاروخي
بصواريخ كروز ثلاث صواريخ وصلت الى
منشاتين صناعيتين كما تقول الاداره
العسكريه هناك ادت الى دمار كبير بهذه
المنشات فيما اسقط صاروخ ايضا وجه الى هذه
المنطقه هذا يضاف الى هجمه مكثفه
بالمسيرات طالت مناطق عده ابتداء من
الشمال الشرقي من خركيف وصولا الى اقصى
الجنوب في اوداسا كان هناك هجمات
بالمسيرات الانتحاريه تقول القوات الجويه
انها اسقطت كل المسيرات التي توجهت الى
هذه المدن هذه ايضا التطورات تاتي
بالتزامن مع قصف بالمدفعيه لمناطق الجبهه
لاسيما في مناطق زابولوجيا عند المناطق
التي تعتبر الاكثر سخونه وهي مناطق
اوريخوف وغيرها من المناطق المحاذيه لها
هناك تم القصف اكثر من 80 مره الليله
واليوم الفائت وما زال القص متواصل حتى
هذه اللحظه يجري الحديث عن اصابات فقط
بصفوف المدنيين وفق الاداره العسكريه
بالاضافه الى دمار كبير كل هذه التطورات
تاتي بالتزامن ايضا مع انتظار زياره
لرئيس الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه هنا
الى تحديدا الى منطقه الجدار الخاضعه
لسيطره القوات الروسيه حيث سيزور هذه
المحطه ويطلع على واقعها بعد ما جرى من
تفجير لسدك خوفكا والتبعات التي يمكن ان
تؤثر على هذه المحطه التي كانت يتم تبريد
المفاعلات بها
واستخدام المياه في
خزان كخوفكا القريب منها لتبريد مفاعلاتها
الا انخفاض منسوب المياه من الممكن ان
يؤثر خلال الفتره القادمه على هذه المحطه
وهو ايضا مسار تباين بين القوات
الاوكرانيه والسلطات الاوكرانيه والسلطات
التي تسيطر على المحطه من الجانب الروسي
التي تريد الجانب
السلطات الاوكرانيه ان يقوم الجانب الروسي
بايقاف اخر المفاعلات هناك ووضعه بخاصيه
التبريد الا ان السلطات الروسيه لا تستجيب
لهذا الطلب ولذلك ناشدت السلطات
الاوكرانيه رئيس الوكاله الدوليه لان يقوم
بدفع تجاه تنفيذ هذا الطلب في حال زيارته
الى انه كان من المفترض ان يزور هذه
المحطه خلال ليوم الماضي لكنه اجل هذه
الزياره الى اليوم ولكن حتى هذه اللحظه لم
يقم بزياره مدينه
وذلك لاسباب امنيه كما قال لا نعلم ان
كانت الزياره ستبقى قائمه ام ان هذه
الزياره يمكن ان تؤجل نظرا لان هذه
المنطقه الواقعه بين
الضفتين ضفتين نهر دنيبر وهذا الذي
تشاهدونه خلفي والذي يفصل ما بين عليها
القوات الاوكرانيه وظيفه التي تسيطر عليها
القوات الروسيه تعتبر منطقه ساخنه منطقه
قصف وقصف متبادل بشكل متواصل بالاضافه الى
سخونه الاوضاع عند الجبهه وعند الممرات
التي يمكن ان يمر بها رئيس الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الدولي الذريه كل ذلك ايضا
يجري بالتزامن مع متابعه اوكرانيا وقائع
اجتماعي رمشتاين نعم
حسان شكرا اذا حسان مسعود من